let's turn to the new york times
best-selling author of red-handed and
government accountability institute
president peter schweitzer
so peter you think hunter is about to be
charged with a crime
i do and jesse i think the best evidence
is the new york times ran this piece
where they admitted the laptop was real
that was in paragraph 17 or 18 but the
story was basically about the grand jury
looking to hunter biden and the new york
times got a lot of cooperation from team
biden and they were clearly trying to
position themselves
on the assumption that hunter biden is
in fact going to be indicted that's why
i think they cooperated and i think the
challenge and the problem they have
jesse is that if hunter biden is
indicted that opens up the whole can of
worms in terms of joe biden's financial
connections that you talked about
earlier
so take us through those connections we
know about credit cards joint bank
accounts we know hunters boys were doing
joe's taxes at one point if dirty money
was coming in from overseas
uh untaxed money and was funneling its
way into joe's pockets what does that
mean in terms of his criminal exposure
uh well it means a couple of things
first you've got the whole national
security component of this because
remember the money that's coming in from
beijing is coming from four businessmen
who funnel at least 31 million dollars
to the bidens that's in the laptop and
when you look at those four businessmen
each and every one of them jesse has
ties to the highest levels of chinese
intelligence so this is not some random
walk around shanghai i'm going to secure
a couple of deals this was orchestrated
but in terms of joe biden's legal
problems he was getting subsidized by
his son paying the monthly bills paying
for renovations on his home up in
delaware
that's not allowed a federal law does
not allow politicians to be subsidized
by family members but you have the other
issue of who's paying the taxes if you
give money to somebody above fifteen
thousand dollars a year somebody's gotta
pay the gift tax on that did joe biden
pay that money did he claim that money
on his income no if you look at the tax
returns his financial disclosures he did
not so this gets messy real fast and the
question jesse becomes does hunter biden
become the sacrificial lamb does he end
up taking a plea deal that might even
mean jail time in order to protect his
father
unbelievable
if that would happen
that's crazy
peter thanks so much for your
investigative work this is uh this has
been eye opening
thank you thanks jesse